okay today I'm going to talk to you
about specific latent heat so specific
latent heat is basically all about the
amount of thermal energy required in
order to change state so remember what
changing state either means is melting
boiling condensing or freezing so let's
just have a quick recap about what's
happening on a kind of atomic level when
we're talking about change of state so
let's say here I've got a substance
these these are different molecules of
that particular substance between those
molecules between those molecules there
are these forces that are called inter
molecular bonds so these are bonds in
between these different molecules in
order let's say this was liquid here in
order for this liquid to turn from a
liquid to a gas I'd need to break these
bonds and energy is required to break
these bonds so I need to heat it up put
thermal energy in and break these
intermolecular bonds so this can turn
from a liquid to a gas
so there's actually an experiment that
we can do and the results really help us
visualize what's happening so what we
can do is we if we get a Bunsen burner
here let's say and on the Bunsen burner
I've got a beaker and within the beaker
I have lots of ice what I can do is I
can actually heat up this heat up the
ice and then read my temperature change
on a thermite er so I'm also going to
need a stop clock right here so here's
my stop clock so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to start heating up my my ice
in my beaker and the second of you I
start my stopwatch then what I do is
every 20 seconds I'm going to record the
temperature on my thermometer
and I should be able to plot my data on
a graph now this is what your data
should look like roughly from this
experiment
so you'd plot temperature on the y-axis
and your time on the x-axis what you
should find is over time it starts to
rise up here now at the beginning in
fact I draw the shape first so this is
what we should find it should look
something like this now let me explain
what we're looking at here now this is
the temperature of the ice at the
beginning of the experiment okay so this
is my temperature of I of my ice which
is obviously a solid so when I'm heating
up the solid there's more energy is
going into the kinetics tour of these of
these particles because they are
vibrating more the more energy we give
them the more that they vibrate
therefore the temperature increases now
this is the bit it's a little bit
strange as the ice starts to melt we do
not have a temperature rise the reason
for that is all of the energy is going
into breaking the intermolecular bonds
within the ice so therefore we get this
flat section here where the temperature
does not go up because all of that
energy is going into breaking but
breaking bonds instead now once all of
that has melted we then have an increase
in temperature again this is when we
have water because it's all melted it's
all now a liquid so again we have an
increase in temperature here because now
it's water liquid we're again just
putting more energy into the kinetic
store or the thermal store of the water
now when we get to this point here again
we have another flat section this is
when boiling has happened again we're
not having a temperature rise because
all of that energy is going into
breaking the intermolecular bonds
between the water molecules in order to
turn it into a gas
so this is when boiling is happening and
finally this section shows steam which
is obviously a gas so what specific
latent heat actually means it's the
amount of energy required in order to
get one kilogram of a substance so one
kilogram of a substance to change to
change state without an increase in
temperature so it's basically we're
thinking about these flat portions of
the graph here that is what specific
latent heat is all about so yeah and the
next thing we need to know is we just
need to know the equation associated
with specific latent heat and how to use
it so here it is right here Q equals M
times L and here's an equation triangle
that kind of shows that as well so Q
stands for thermal energy so this is the
thermal energy that would be putting in
in order to change state the M is simply
the mass of the liquid that we're
changing which is measured in kilograms
and finally L that's substantial a
specific latent heat specific latent
heat and that units specific specific
latent heat is joules per kilogram so
let's just imagine this let's say that
we're told the specific latent heat for
water is three hundred and thirty-four
joules per kilogram you don't need to
know this number you'd always be given a
specific latent heat your question might
be how much thermal energy is required
in order to change the state of 500
grams of of water and then you'd be
given this value here so all you'd need
to do is use this equation now please
notice this is in grams we need to
convert to kilograms so you'd have to do
this 500 divided by a thousand which
equals 0.5 so to find the specific
latent heat of this substance
you'd simply do 0.5 x 3 3 4 and let's
see what that would give you 167 so the
amount of thermal energy required in
order to change 500 grams change the
state of 500 grams of water would be a
hundred and sixty-seven joules so the
final thing we need to know is just two
more terms so there's two different
types of a specific latent heat if we're
talking about either melting or freezing
this is called the specific latent heat
of fusion and if we're thinking about
boiling or condensing this is called the
specific latent heat of vaporization and
a final final point a lot of people get
specific latent heat and procedure
specific heat capacity confused a nice
little way to try and remember which
ones which
is latent has got eight in it and so
does state so this one is about changing
state and that is about it thank you